Although you guys were arguing a lot earlier, it
really did seem that your ideas compliment one another in
a way that gives us a global perspective on how
traits exist and are passed down from generation to generation.
>> Yeah, like Mendel. Your theory does a
really good job of explaining how traits skip generations.
>> And, Skinner, I guess you do have a
handle on understanding how the environment affects various traits. And
I suppose you guys did a pretty good job
of explaining the biological components. But, I bet the genome
has still many more secrets, that we don't even know.
>> Based on the fabulous work you guys did along with many others,
we knew what the hereditary material did, before we even knew what it was.
>> Although DNA, the hereditary material, was first isolated
in 1869 It's exact nature was a mystery until 1953 when work
by Rosalyn Franklin, Maurice Wilkins, James Watson, and Francis Crick
revealed the structure, and began to unravel the secretes of
how DNA codes for many of our traits. And we've
come a long way since then as well. We've learned
how DNA makes up our genomes and codes for many
of our traits. And technology's advancing at an ever-increasing pace,
allowing people to obtain personal information about their very own
DNA. We're in an unique age of genomic information, and
this course is going to give you an introductory look
at how you can use this information.